the latest figures today say it's at
32.8 and the governments have decided
that that is high enough
for this now to be designated an area of
intervention so it now joins
uh four and a half million other people
in the uh in parts of west yorkshire
east lancashire greater manchester and
so on 130 000 population preston will
now join them
in these restrictions it's not a
lightning lock down it doesn't mean that
pubs and restaurants and businesses
have to close but what it does mean is
that people have to take much more care
with their
social contact the rules are that you
can't have anyone else
in your home or garden you can't visit
other people's homes or gardens even if
they are
outside the restricted areas and you're
not allowed to permit
you're not permitted to mix with other
households in indoor venues so it means
you can still go
to pubs you stan can still go to
restaurants and
indoor areas but you cannot mix with
other people outside your family group
once you're there now lancaster council
have given details on this today they
say that
the announcement comes following the
release of data in the areas of the city
most affected by the recent rise of
cases we've heard from
a statement from the chief executive of
preston city council
adrian phillips he says a number of
cases in preston have increased rapidly
in recent days
leading to government categorizing the
city as an area of intervention
it's also alarming to see he says that
the under 30s
are contracting it at a significant rate
uh it's clear that current virus is
still here he says
and we all need to work together to keep
ourselves our friends families and
communities
safe from this virus there's going to be
a press conference in the next 10
minutes or so hosted by lancashire
county council
their word on this is that they are
monitoring it closely and that
if there is any further increase
following the
the introduction of these uh these new
restrictions then they will certainly
consider stricter restrictions
in the coming weeks and perhaps months
so it's the news that people here in
preston didn't want to hear
there is going to be an extension of
those restrictions which we've seen
across much of
east lancashire greater manchester uh
and parts of west yorkshire uh not the
news that they wanted here but
andy burnham the mayor of greater
manchester this morning before this
announcement was made that there isn't
going to be any lifting of those
added restrictions he was saying he
didn't want that to be he thought that
the numbers were still bad enough
to warrant those extra restrictions
being in place and now preston is
following suit